what's going on world this is gq
recommends we are here to talk about
swimsuits
[Music]
from the fit to the best colors whether
you're going to the pool whether you're
going to the beach wherever you're
headed this summer
the classics
all right young so walk me through the
first category we're talking about so
right now we're going to talk about the
classic swim trunks you know like if you
are just looking to buy your first pair
of swim trunks in a long while these are
probably the ones you want to start with
they come in a length that i personally
think is sort of the ideal length for
most body types what is that length it's
a five inch inseam that's something that
you'll hear about in in menswear talk
people love a five inch inseam it's not
too baggy and long it's not too short
and cropped it is kind of just hits you
right in the middle of your thigh like
right where you want it to be the first
pair we're gonna talk about are probably
the most essential
men's swim trunks in my opinion and
those are the patagonia baggies well
what i really like is basically what you
touched on already they hit exactly
where you want them to on the thigh and
they have a really flattering somewhat
baggy fit hence the name but the great
thing about these is that they won't
only look great on someone with shawn's
build they will also look great on
basically any build right because of
that universally flattering cut yeah i
would call these like a default swim
trunk if you just need swim trunks and
you need them to be practical you can
wear them all the time baggies are
probably your best affordable bet and
you know they have all these other great
features that things that you want in a
pair of swim trunks they have big
pockets they've got two on the sides
they've got a handy one in the back for
your wallet that buttons down they've
got an elastic waist which is actually
going to look better on more body types
you know i think sometimes a tie waist
only looks good on sort of slimmer
silhouettes and these are going to look
good on pretty much everyone they've got
that nice stretch they're made from
recycled materials they are easy to wash
they're easy to dry these are it if
you're looking for swim trunks you could
style them just like you would any other
pair of shorts you already have yeah
they're great basic pair of shorts
that's why you see so many guys like you
know jonah hill is a guy that loves
these you'll pair them with vintage
t-shirts you can rock them with a
button-down you can wear them with a
blazer even like they are very very easy
to style they'll go with a ton of things
and they come in all these dope colors
so no matter what need you have there's
probably a pair of baggies out there for
you
so avnan if you wanted to step things up
from a patagonia baggie let's say you
have some baggies or they just feel a
little too basic for you where would you
go next i'd probably turn to a brand
like bather which makes a really cool
bathing suit that's cut pretty similarly
to the baggies that we were just talking
about a little more visual oomph so as
you can see these bathers have a very
similar cut to the baggies that sean was
just wearing they're the same sort of
five inch inseam the same sort of
slightly baggy fit but on rondelle they
fit a little bit differently they're a
little bit higher but they are just as
flattering and i assume feel pretty good
right you feel pretty good in them yeah
yeah you know what's cool about them is
like yeah they hit a lot of those same
points we were just talking about they
have pockets on the side they have
pockets on the back they have that
elastic waistband they're made from
recycled materials they're made in my
hometown of toronto which is a really
beautiful thing there's some great
beaches there and they come in a ton of
really cool patterns every season like
this dope checkerboard these are just a
cool sort of modern update to that
classic baggie that we were just talking
about
and finally avadon if you wanted a ball
outrageous on a pair of swim trunks what
are the ones you would drop a bag on i
would probably go to a place like one of
our brown where you can get a super
streamlined pair of swim trunks that are
actually worthy of the moniker of being
like an elevated swim trunk they're cut
like the same pair of swanky dress pants
that you used to rely on in your nine to
five they have side tabs a super sleek
cut they hit pretty high up on the thigh
and they'll always make you look cool no
matter where you're wearing them pretty
pricey but for all that money what
you're getting is essentially a really
cool pair of dress shorts that happen to
be waterproof and beach ready it's a
great color they come in a wide array of
stripes and patterns they still have
that very very flattering cut on pretty
much all body types they also just look
sick they really do yeah yeah these are
definitely the kind of swim trunks you
could see dressing up with a blazer
wearing out to like a nice dinner after
the beach yeah if you're on vacation
these are the fancy swim trunks for your
nice nights out you're telling me that
you could plausibly wear these with a
blazer i
would in fact wow yeah huge
in terms of uh style icons dolph
lundgren is a great example of what
we're talking about here you know he is
a bigger guy he is huge he beat up rocky
in rocky iv and yet that five inch
inseam that classic swim trunk looks
perfect on his body it hits him in all
the right places and he was able to sort
of dress it up here you know he's got a
button down on he's got a six shades on
he's looking really good yeah i think
it's also would you say a testament to
the power of a really good swimsuit you
can basically throw on just like a clean
white dress shirt and very minimal
accessories and still look pretty put
together
[Music]
the show off
now we're going to pivot to talk about
the show-off which is like the wild
style version of the classic whether
it's because it's crazy pattern crazy
colors or because the cut quite frankly
is a little bit trimmer than you would
expect definitely a slightly different
silhouette than the classic bathing
suits we were talking about earlier but
they're oozing and retro charms you're
gonna see guys like jfk junior wearing
it timeless very classic but also
extremely of the moment and always cool
it's a little
not as short as like a speedo but
obviously if you can pull off a speedo
by all means pull off a speedo you can
pull off a speedo go for a speed yeah
that's your number one option so first
up these are the cldb swim shorts as you
can see way shorter than your average
from trunk so rondelle you said that
these are slightly shorter than you
would normally go right yeah a little
bit shorter than i usually go you still
feel comfortable in mine
yeah i mean they look fantastic
i like that they hit really high up on
the thigh there it's kind of a classic
look that we were talking about kyle
very very retro leaning it's a great
color too so yeah not too loud
trying to make a statement with more
than just the length this is definitely
the right way to do it exactly but still
has all the benefits of your typical
swim truck very breathable the mesh
lining inside great pockets
so as you can see on rondelle here who
is taller you're a 6-3 rondelle they
still look great they'll definitely draw
some attention to your legs sure but if
you've got legs why not show them off
exactly there you go if you have the
confidence pull them off
another sweet pair in a similar price
range is the one we have here from true
tribe yes which are really cool because
they've got this kind of satiny finish
that makes them shimmer
in the light very iridescent glow right
so it's a slightly different cut than
the last one we were talking about the
cdlp is because it's trimmer as well but
there's got a little bit of bagginess to
it it has a heft it's very much inspired
by like a 90s era running shorts it has
those side gussets and deep pockets
really nice almost shiny finish that we
were talking about before just an
overall great way to flex at the beach
or on the boardwalk wherever your summer
surgeons happen to take you exactly and
i feel like these are a great step
forward from the casual look the other
ones that we just showed off they were
more fitting and more fitting around
your legs so it shows off the definition
of your body so what i really like about
these also is that john you're five five
and they still look great on you because
they have that pretty sweet slightly
mid-length cut they're definitely longer
than the pair that rhondella was wearing
earlier but in the same way that like a
classic pair of patagonia baggies are
almost universally flattering so are
these because they're cut with a little
bit more room around the thigh
i feel great i feel like the star of the
beach the bathing suit doesn't make you
react that way sorry exactly you have a
different bathing suit
rtg if the last two weren't loud enough
yeah these versace swim shorts lay it on
me hard i'm ready above and beyond we're
about to see it you're about to see it
yeah kyle tell me what are we looking at
here what's malik wearing everything
loud here is is definitely here the
print itself the colors the vibrant
colors the length the material it's all
very super light super loud there's no
way you're you're walking on the beach
without breaking necks yeah i think what
works here particularly well is that
because it's this sort of
retro cut you can get away with having a
ton of fun with the colors and if you're
going to wear versace you might as well
wear something like this if you're going
to be shelling out a solid amount of
money for a bathing suit you might as
well have fun with it you can't really
go wrong here how do you fill in these
yeah
yeah
yeah you look good these are dancing
shorts you're in the club in these i
would say like again these are an absurd
amount of money objectively speaking to
spend on a bathing suit but if you're
looking for a swimsuit with serious
designer pedigree that's going to make
you
the loudest person on the beach there's
no better brand to turn to than versace
it's a miami mainstay for a reason they
make incredibly loud lavish baroque
menswear and these look really sick i
used it speaking of loud prince we have
actor luke evans who was just killing it
at the beach with this wild prince short
yeah what do you like about these these
it's it's more about the st's of the
confidence of rocking them less than the
print itself being able to just master
that you're saying when you're wearing a
bathing suit like that there's an
overall aura that you start to eliminate
the bathing suit almost becomes
secondary to the point exactly great
argument for buying one
the board shorts
so when i say board shorts what's the
first thing that comes to mind
definitely length right board shorts are
longer for surfers to protect their legs
hopping on and off these boards all day
and also like the more technical aspect
of it you know when it comes out to the
fabric being more quick dry so getting
hit by wave after wave after wave and so
have your shorts looking fresh and clean
when soon as you get out of the water
you know a lot of these other swim
trunks we've been talking about yes
they're great for sports like yes you
can wear them on a hike or you can wear
them to the beach but these are made
with a real purpose in mind and that
purpose is surfing the first pair we're
going to talk about are the most classic
board shorts there are these are the
birdwell reach bridges that's a mouthful
the birdwell beach bridges they invented
the board short essentially these are
the original board shorts they were made
in southern california in the 1960s and
they're made of this like really
nice
tough nylon that like you said can get
bashed by a wave they're not gonna get
torn or ripped in the ocean they define
what modern board shorts should be so
they have really tough construction
you'll see all this triple stitching
instead of the elastic waistbands we've
been seeing a lot of today they have
this lace front which is great because
it means you can tighten them as much as
you possibly can they're gonna stay
never fall off they're never falling off
no matter what you face in the ocean and
then you also notice that they don't
have side pockets which is normally
something that i love in my swim trunks
but you don't want that bulk that extra
bulk that a pocket provides when you're
surfing you want to keep things
streamlined you want to keep things
close to your body so they only have one
back pocket here which is still pretty
handy yeah
so these have that old school vibe we
were talking about they're very retro
really really cool look they definitely
have a slightly longer in seam than the
other ones we were talking about these
are probably closer to like a seven or
nine inch as opposed to the five inch on
the baggies and the and the more classic
styles it's very bare bones but it's
everything you need to show off your
stuff on a surfboard exactly so let's
say you're not a fan of birdwell's old
school looks what is something that is a
little more modern if someone wanted to
grab a pair of board shorts roan is
definitely the option to go to they make
such a great more modern looking in
modern feeling board short it feels more
like a
compression or like a workout short that
most people are used to wearing to like
the gym
right off the bat you can sort of see
there are some real similarities to the
bird wells in terms of the tie waist and
sort of the longer cut but as maliki's
showing off these are much stretchier
fabric and and they definitely have like
a much sleeker more modern cut than what
we're used to exactly yeah again very
sleek cut on the back with that single
pocket design so these are a great
option if you're looking for something a
little bit more modern and a little bit
stretchier a little more active i feel
like i could do yoga in those if i
wanted to for sure yeah run yeah you've
got a lot of gives which
so if i was a pro looking for a great
pair of swim trunks where would i go if
you are a serious serious high level
surfer then you're going to want to get
the outer known apex trunks outer known
is the brand owned by kelly slater who's
like the greatest surfer of all time
he's the michael jordan of this thing
and these are his trunks these are the
ones that he designed for himself to his
own specifications so they are like top
of the line technical surf trunks and
they're going to perform at the highest
highest level like as you can see these
are super sleek just like the the rhone
ones but to almost an even greater
degree they're like almost like ninja
like they're covert they have all these
like black on black details which look
really really sick very sleek very
simple yeah super super modern again
they do have pockets but these are
smaller pockets they're very slim
they're going to stay put when you're
when you're surfing and you know they
have this really cool zip pocket on the
back on the back that has all these tape
seams completely waterproof nothing's
getting in there that's right everything
here is designed to be as tight and as
performance-minded and technical as
possible for sure so even though
these board shorts are cut longer than
your typical swim trunk they still will
look really good on a whole variety of
body types of no matter what your height
is because they have a very tailored cut
they're not too big and voluminous
they're not going to like overtake you
so like even if you're a little shorter
than rondell is here they're still going
to look good on you because you know
they'll be cut a little bit closer to
your leg and sort of account for that
exactly exactly and through the three
pairs that we've seen here there is
still a little bit of wiggle room of
like how you want them to look like the
very retro relaxed look and then the
more form-fitting technical look of
these right all right all right all
right matthew mcconaughey loves himself
some board shorts he never has a shirt
on and he's always got his board shorts
covering his legs why do you think he
loves him so much for one thing i think
he's just always at the beach if he's
not in a movie he's at the beach it's
all the time with some sunglasses no
shirt that guy loves he does so how
would you style this look either going
to the beach or
somewhere else yeah you know you got to
just keep living when you're wearing a
pair of board shorts hanahe does a great
job of that of just you know these are
probably the most casual style of swim
trunks that we're talking about today
you know a lot of these other ones that
we've seen they lend themselves well to
dressing up to maybe wearing a button up
on top or throwing it on with a blazer
like we said but these are really
strictly for the beach look best with
some flip-flops and an old t-shirt and
some sunglasses that's going to get you
by super mcconaughey for sure
[Music]
so that's it those are the three main
kinds of swim trunks out there for dudes
seems like there's really a great option
for pretty much everybody kyle which
ones are you going to be rocking this
summer uh definitely more casual route
but you know every now and again
wouldn't mind throwing in one of those
shorter ones just to spice things up
absolutely man you got to show off
sometimes
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you learned a lot hope you buy some
brand new swim trunks and let us know in
the comments below which ones you grab
[Music]